zum einen glauben wir dass die abkehr
von der umfassende individuelle
nachverfolgung persönlicher kontakte die
ja wenn wir ehrlich sind bereits lange
realität ist stattfinden muss ist schon
seit wochen und monaten in vielen
gesundheitsämtern nicht mehr möglich
gewesen
nach versorgung zu gewährleisten wir
glauben noch ein ampelsystem bundesweit
einheitlich mit dem regional dann
reagiert werden kann würde die sache
deutlich vereinfacht und viel
transparenter gestalten und damit auch
die akzeptanz der bevölkerung erhöhen
wir glauben das ist sinnvoll ist die
konzentration der ressourcen auf den
schutz von bevölkerungsgruppen zu
konzentrieren ein besonders hohes risiko
für schwere krankheitsverläufe haben das
sind die hochbezahlten und die vor
erkrankten und wir glauben und das ist
unsere ärztliche und etliches
menschenbild dass man die bevölkerung
zur mitarbeit anhalten soll das ja auch
compliance sitzen auf gebote und nicht
überwiegend auch vermute über diese
vorschläge hinaus geführt worden wir
natürlich ausdrücklich die anwendung der
regeln ergänzt um a und l das ist app
und lüftung jetzt im winter
wir sollten eine priorisierung der
kontakt nach verfolgung machen nach den
kriterien bezug zur medizinisch
pflegerischen einrichtungen teilen wir
von kontaktpersonen an potenziellen
inklusion großen events wir haben
insgesamt seit beginn der pandemie eine
zahl von 463 1419 cobit diagnosen
insgesamt mit der unsicherheit die wir
das hat die whu gerade verkündet mit
wahrscheinlich einer vielfachen
unterschätzung der insgesamten infektion
rechnen müssen verstorbene und 10.000
über 320.000 genesen und aktuell 125000
positiv gemeldet auch die zahl
wahrscheinlich eher zu niedrig selbst
wenn wie heute
medienwirksam zu lesen ist eine menge
falsch positive befunde in den laboren
gegeben hat das scheint allerdings kein
systematisches problem haben es mit den
laboren abgestimmt sondern ist natürlich
den wänden druck geschuldet neben dieser
moore arbeiten müssen und dem
überbordenden anfangen mit tests was
dazu führt dass rund 100000
testergebnisse noch gar nicht gefunden
worden sind
wir glauben es ist nicht eine kennzahl
wichtig also nicht nur die zahl der
aktuell infizierten sondern es sind
diese punkte die viel entscheiden also
die hospitalisierung 's quote natürlich
der intensivmedizinischen
behandlungsbedarf und wie positiv quote
bei den pcs und wenn wir mit der
spezialisierung squaw zu beginnen dann
liegt die in der kalender
und bei fünf prozent das sind eckpunkte
die sind wichtig das ist eine
rekordmenge an tests mit bekannten
problemen die aus dieser maximal auslass
von der labor resultieren aber es gibt
weitaus wichtiger indikatoren als die
reine zahl der absoluten tests sondern
es ist natürlich die frage infizierten
in den höheren altersgruppen denn wir
wissen gerade die über 60 jährigen haben
ein höheres risiko für schwere verläufe
und die mortalitätsrate liegt dann auch
deutlich über den sonst üblichen 1
prozent oder sogar geringer von daher
schlagen wir auch vor das sich auf diese
person fabriziert werden sollte dass
kontakt nachverfolgen etc angeht
dafür brauchen wir natürlich gewisse
daten auf der kreisebene aber das ist
eine maßnahme die wir dann vor ort
zusammenfassend sind das die ersten
eckpunkte die wir für eine medizinisch
begründete und wahrscheinlich mit eine
deutlich größere akzeptanz belegte
strategie verfolgen was wir sehen ist
dass der schutz der risikogruppen
eigentlich zu kurz kommt ist
wir haben zwar natürlich das hoffen
reingeschickt altenheime pflegeheime
krankenhäuser besser zu schützen aber
auch zu testen aber das wird nicht
systematisch gemacht es wird auch nicht
versucht für risikogruppen etwas zu
entwickeln wo wir eine möglichkeit haben
die ezb zu hause leben für die reine
möglichkeit haben dort einen schutz zu
etablieren also zum beispiel
nachbarschaftshilfen für die leute die
sich selber isolieren wollen oder ffp
zwei masken für die leute die zu hause
bleiben wollen aber zum beispiel einen
besucher empfangen wollen ihre enkel
sehen wollen
wir haben aber auch keine vier
testmöglichkeiten für zuhause dass leute
die sich ja für die wintermonate zu
hause bleiben wollen isolieren wollen
dass dort auch besucher getestet werden
können infektionszahlen alleine auf die
infektion star anzuschauen ist in
unseren augen zu wenig auf
intensivbetten zu schauen und da sind
wir natürlich alle auch einer meinung
ist
zu spät es muss etwas geben wie wir die
pandemie besser einschätzen können und
auch einschätzen können wie es sich
langfristig verhält das problem
passieren in dieser pandemie haben dass
es sich nicht um einen kurzen sprint
handelt derjenige der glaubt dass wir in
zwei monaten hierdurch sind wenn wir
jetzt uns alle am riemen reißen der der
liegt halt dem liegt der irrglaube
zugrunde dass man glaubt dass durch den
impfstoff alleine oder andere maßnahmen
das bios weg gehen wird das virus wird
teil unseres lebens bleiben und auch
wenn ein impfstoff da ist werden wir
noch jahre mit diesem virus zu tun haben
daher ist es sehr viel wichtiger dass
wir uns auf diesen marathon vorbereiten
nicht diesen kurzen sprint sondern ein
marathon dass wir auch über gebote reden
dass die macht zum beispiel sexy wird
dass wir einen weg haben mit leben
zuzulassen ohne andere menschen zu
gefährden
was wir jetzt einen vorstoß hier haben
ist einen ist nicht die patentlösung für
alles sondern ist so eine grundlage zu
einer diskussion geben eine grundlage
für viele fachbereiche aus der medizin
aber auch aus vielen anderen bereichen
des lebens und der gesellschaft
die diskussion aufzunehmen wir haben in
den sommermonaten ist nicht geschafft
die kontakte vollends nachzuverfolgen
und die pandemie einzudämmen in
deutschland dass wir keinen
infektionsgeschehen mehr haben sondern
und wir müssen davon absehen dass wir
schaffen würden jetzt im herbst unter
mit wirklich schon überlasteten
gesundheitsämtern die kontaktpersonen
nachverfolgung als alleiniges mittel
einwerben punkte sondern vorne und
müssen für uns in unseren augen in die
fokussierung der ressourcen auf die
risikogruppen seien sowohl die in alten
und pflegeheimen krankenhäusern als auch
in den die zu hause sind und
risikogruppen